I love the century Massa they finally
caught him the famous goal also dog
that's walking like don't [ __ ] around
school kids right
did you just got busted for [ __ ]
somebody up - if he gets exonerated for
I'm gonna give me a [ __ ] Willy
t-shirt sideways on Instagram twelve men
in a room a movie man we're so full
podcast what's a full podcast welcome to
the Warsaw a full podcast we have with
real tours right here Eric we've run a
Batman from tanning salon Joshua Johnny
broke in saving lives that's all natural
nothing as long as right here on the
Wheels of Steel
we got Marty Moreno mess straight from
the [ __ ] how did mansion dog
we weren't [ __ ] Las Vegas bro leave a
shout-out to Rachel Wulff Astaire Wolf
Wolf sin and her 18 people showed up
hell yeah dude and then her father sold
out Sacramento they bought tickets for
free [ __ ] bones drop man did ya
everybody lookin for the carbon now so
wait wait you guys were doing shows out
Vegas yeah okay how'd that go it was
good bro man let me tell you man
when I was driving I saw Gabriel
Iglesias billboard
then I saw mine the next yeah my room I
saw far away I saw Michael Tonio Solis
follow bookies okay
maluma and I saw Bruno Mars and as a fog
bro like I got a goose bro that's
[ __ ] awesome five dollars to see us
bro are they gonna choose now yeah hell
yeah bro is good bro happy and together
booked the Treasure Island he was happy
ship right away bro you want me back
next year or whenever whenever [ __ ] and
you reach decide to fight a fight a
fight on the [ __ ] Vegas I think he
fights on Saturday I'll be there on
Friday abroad you know in the [ __ ] do
the comedy show on Friday or everybody
drives up to the show then you can see
the fight on Saturday I'll be gone on
Saturday that's a new for right there
and the ruies bar next fights Saudi
Arabian is it I think so I think yeah
we're gonna come back don't get Mac dad
I think I'm gonna go other brother just
blew up our oil tanker over there
supposedly Oh [ __ ] gas prices went to
[ __ ] up an excuse bro any excuse but
it's always a wardrobe right before the
election huh we catch somebody Oh
presidents who have war they're usually
reelected that was brilliant Obama
cuddle oh we caught Osama Osama Ladin
ma'am and there wasn't named truck he
just killed his son oh that's right
Osama skid and Foley before a good photo
of here brother
how come they didn't kill him when they
were shooting their photo like anybody
from their photo somewhere
how come you didn't do the connection
emoji that poured away okay would you
get it from
and then finally get up they know where
he's at bro yes that's a [ __ ]
convenient now it's like we were Frank
Sinatra tonight we got Frank Sinatra jr.
[ __ ] I don't know yeah I don't know we
were fighting inside yeah [ __ ]
mastermind I'm gonna get the Sklar
brothers who are [ __ ] let's go
I don't need ear cancer right now
[ __ ] ah [ __ ] Jimmy and Tony
whatever they're called Joey but I think
he was a leader of some new goddamn
terrorist yeah what have they done
how do we know this is even a bro you
know the [ __ ] making a name for
themselves and before they blow up they
got a [ __ ] stop but how do you make
it is it like an open-mike for these
groups like they cancelled was so full
so man I love your original Treasure
Island theater but that theater belongs
to the circus Olay miss mistake so other
costumes are backstage bro for the first
about man I couldn't try them all I can
normally do it when I see costumes
nobody could fit in these may be new bro
really yeah oh you've been walking
around with [ __ ] backstage forever you
can wear a feather bro
so this boot tables vector visage tape
massage chairs man look a sex swing
David little kiddies Pilates sex bed
though
hey bro what [ __ ] theater where we
out when you and mondo were fighting
with swords in the middle of Gabe set
somewhere I don't [ __ ] from back [ __ ]
stage no was it Sacramento I don't know
where I just remember you'd be backstage
finding [ __ ] and just taking it on stage
like it was funny like you're a part of
the production bro I opened up for a
part down low they had a Fab Four or
Beatlemania back there and I put on all
the Beatle wigs out bro honey what won't
aired at her house in [ __ ] Mexico
they were called me Ringo Starr Broyles
okay see kids would know why hey [ __ ]
out Ringo Starr you know like talking
this you know just not you shake because
you're like bucket list whatever [ __ ]
hippie they're like take it's Tom Araya
from Slayer right yeah they don't know
if Tom Araya bro no one notices that guy
for the man
we mask with [ __ ] assurance don't be
the busky sarsaparilla value Oh martín
burrito so many Kurt's worse dude what
the [ __ ] you talking about
right out of your way Cassidy the dude
abides what so whoever Dimona were so
much in what in a man what's up Felipe
thank you for having me back I was a
pleasure to be on the what's up for
podcasts we're asking about you bro
well you [ __ ] Megaman bro been asking
for what you making bro you [ __ ] move
that's a different a large yeah yeah the
last time I was here you were in the
lurching Adelita a little small one that
was all the white walls oh yeah now this
is [ __ ] nice bro you're steppin
you're moving up in the pinche mundo bro
we got people logging in bro no you
start with Randy's right there bro you
know what lissa look at doing the
chhotya stuff tremendous Lisa we need a
new enchilada podcast you know what
laughs ah what's a fool [ __ ] a dude
you got a hardcore [ __ ] fans bro
what's up fools here I guarantee Frank
Avila say that's all right man I wanna
know bro we saw all the glacial episodes
Oliver who saw it yeah I want to know
how come they make you the janitor with
no line well you could've been a push
broom you talking about
I could have been a good looking coach
he would have been a drummer Oh Larry Oh
weighted breathing when the [ __ ]
devil with a foot with a janitor and
belamis oh yeah mr. entertainment the
devil was the janitor on Bill Bellamy
sure yeah entertainment they showed that
[ __ ] um Byron Allen by redundant
producer she comes out at 4:00 in the
morning bro you ever get locked up
arresting you got to community service
yeah he's a celebrity he has to do Bill
Bellamy is and then but yeah the devil
plays the janitor well even named the
manager restaurant II the manager gear
manager of the Palacio de Blasio restore
a great time yeah um not didn't [ __ ]
you know think it has to be on it so you
know it's uh I don't know that who's
responsible for doing the casting I
thought when you have a show they take
that you got full control of that [ __ ]
you know how much how much control does
somebody have you when they give you a
show and it's like a [ __ ] there's a
lot of people that have falling outs
with networks because they wanted to go
this direction no matter how great I
know my dear Omaha he said that didn't
want him to be on Comedy Central and
it's like hey bro are you a communist
and just to get him on to get a set on
there yeah to get uh to get them to do a
stand-up set which is a lot different
than again you know [ __ ] who knows
bro I don't [ __ ] you know [ __ ] it but
you're ready though hot sauce season two
you ready no mechanic teacher bro there
you go
bull shop teacher shop to shop reporter
lady person it could be like the crazy
history teacher bro that were too crazy
brought to the kids on that economy the
crazy history teacher that took half the
kids to a protest and the other arrested
he gets fired he's done [ __ ] in a
nurse used to be a salon kids don't
listen to the posted well that's [ __ ]
funny bro cafeteria workers being dudes
bro this is why we're marching for
[ __ ] equality why the [ __ ] cafeteria
workers always fighting oh yeah it
should be chortles were there and then
there you go
have you no coverage area workers least
that's a damn with that raus bonds bonds
there's a woman there or man said I
bring 31 years she said what's that
congratulations congratulations man if I
had only stayed at my lunch lady job I
had back whenever I would have had about
35 years but I'm like damn you're
looking you're looking back fondly on
the lunch lady job like that's it was
sad you know but she's got the benefits
in the lunches they should have been
gone it's when ebrill slit my wrists in
that job because yeah they started
making the kids serve the food instead
of the ladies but also they brought in
like Cisco another like corporate yeah
corporate outsourcing of those things
yeah dude you know the days of people
stayin at a [ __ ] job forever are done
broke your little theater forever bro
you in a wheel stay in the place forever
is [ __ ] gone bro for him you know
people used to wait for the gold watch
and [ __ ] the retirement [ __ ]
election gather now you go somewhere and
it's like this is just until I get to
here this is just until I get to here we
live in a whole different [ __ ] world
I know but the last guy I know that had
the job forever will let the custodian
in my elementary school Rudy hmm and
therefore they're like how long ago was
your elementary school
[Laughter]
thirty years probably that's a long
[ __ ] time ah penis off I think people
well I think people started waking up so
about twenty years ago or so and
realizing well these employers aren't
doing anything for me they're not loyal
to me
so why should I be loyal then I'm gonna
follow my dreams or I'm gonna try to you
know do my own [ __ ] do my own thing
get you know go wherever I'm most
appreciated or paid the most or given
the most time off or whatever there or
have a side hustle even if you're a dude
that's doing like landscaping you know
your gardener and [ __ ] and the next you
know you're like [ __ ]
by my own goddamn lawn mower we'll put
it in the back of my truck [ __ ] what
are you babies Mexican le multiplying
with these truck bro
that's the thing it's like you're gonna
be like alright you're gonna pay me
minimum wage I can just go and knock on
doors and say hey man [ __ ] all more your
lawn you know I you need the rise of the
contract for 80 bucks a month there you
go and it's like that that's just a one
example I mean and that just escalates
all the way to the top to the top levels
and [ __ ] you know of Commerce we got
I don't know if we should be talking
like this yeah first of all when I when
you just said Trump and jobs and [ __ ]
people are talking about [ __ ]
Mexicans are taking jobs away from
Americans no [ __ ] corporations are
taking jobs to Mexico or minimum wage is
$10 a [ __ ] day and that's why it's
better to make Levi's over there it's
not [ __ ] Mexicans coming here to take
the jobs that [ __ ] corporations
taking jobs to Mexico they're taking the
jobs there to Mexico another 15 bucks an
hour or [ __ ] 10 bucks a day ten bucks
a day all day me huh you know I'm
[ __ ] just [ __ ] yeah if you if you
watch shark tank that's the first thing
they ask and they start talking about
like how much does it cost to produce
one of the right and then they'll tell
them what have you ever thought about
production over shipping changing
production overseas well you know I know
some manufacturers we can do this for
this price point and all that stuff but
that's all they're caring about
american-made in 15 hours ago vanilla
now 15 cents I thought that well I got
some Chinamen oh they'll do for free
don't you say [ __ ] not offensive
you're gonna get cancelled out of these
sample gets canceled mulligans got off
for 500 million dollars to go to Netflix
yeah with the same letter just said yeah
the guy goes that did that the main guy
goes oh man this is gonna cost us so
much money ain't why don't you go to the
[ __ ] yeah cuz he used to work in
text let's [ __ ]
in word that Michael Richard said small
potatoes I was talking about this news
O'Shea I was taught I was talking about
this the other day with hooter on the
podcast on the yoyoyo
let me just drop the yoyoyo podcast I'll
always but listen no here's the thing
Thursday out of all the things I've said
in my life you know there's a ringtone
on Pandora that you pay for that's an
old joke of mine where it says honk honk
that's my cell phone [ __ ] you know and
now I'm gonna say n-word ah when they're
selling it they're you know they're
selling it there with me screaming the
[ __ ] word I'm gonna get out of it
nothing about my so no [ __ ] idea what
some [ __ ] that I recorded up Rick from
pezzini's who knows who the [ __ ] did it
but anyway here's a photo here's the
thing here's the thing it's like you
know if we say a lot of stupid [ __ ] on
stage trying to be funny that could be
considered offensive [ __ ] you know
when you just take that one out from
them any any time you know when you take
it oh yeah but again like so so you know
we're really like we were so quick to
say [ __ ] song so said this I've said
so many stupid things throughout my
[ __ ] life that if somebody had a
camera on me 24/7
I'd be canceled from [ __ ] living bro
you know I'm saying and and I'll say
like [ __ ] Jesus said let he who is
free of talking [ __ ] cast the first
stone [ __ ] you know everybody
said some stupid everybody's talk [ __ ]
[ __ ] everybody wants to be an angel
in the career air do people put them
real selves up nobody nobody over here
bro I'm trying to be honest and also if
we could tone this now
what you had before stand up I was a
pharmacy technician at CVS that you
[ __ ] I counted pills co2 pills and
then the pharmacist was check it over
and but I had a lab coat on my mom would
bring all her church friends over and
they would give me their diagnosis like
I was a doctor [ __ ] yeah
I worked at an urgent care and I was the
neighborhood yeah I was prescribing Miho
put the jacket on mijo put it tell them
that's Coolio and you cannot be cured
but everybody's full of [ __ ] everybody
wants to abide by these rules and yeah
answer everybody everybody wants to be a
[ __ ] hall monitor now everybody dude
I mean who really kind of speaks their
mind like as far as even comedians
probably what Coco yeah that's right
yeah my people like that real [ __ ] and
he's only a bull she got it his whole
[ __ ] career it's not like he just
started doing that for the shock value
exactly and there's a you know and then
you got your copycats you know yeah
you're [ __ ] Joey cocoa lights where
everybody's trying to do the shock
ballot you know exactly my first funny
is funny bro [ __ ] yeah a lot of racist
jokes growing up I read on my books and
they were far me like not funny and
racist yeah brother the New York abs
joke book the new tab that was joke
bully web got all my great do you
remember any of them the races was yeah
hell yeah blood like when all four
Mexicans drowning cuatro Sinko what you
said go yeah yeah I was you know how do
you know if I'll you know when you're in
a I didn't know there's a lot of them
bro like how do you know the Italian guy
is it like in a cockfight how the dog
wins Jackie the joke man busted all
those jokes yeah yeah I don't know those
in that book does then you kept your
book yeah I mean they bribe everybody
and they [ __ ] blown by the duck huh
the duck wind dark blows somebody to
tell you no stupid Chinese a bribe
everybody
yeah they bribe not fight so they
[ __ ]
took me 10 years to figure that out so
one of them is a duh yeah look I think
that I just was insane [ __ ] before that
one exactly I know the Polish guy isn't
a [ __ ] fight he bets on a duck how you
know the challenge either cockfight wins
are you [ __ ] a [ __ ] fight but a duck
wins cuz the Italian the mob the [ __ ]
a the [ __ ] dogs gonna win you calling
some Tony broke bad at ease
that's a good do now when Melissa be a
senior came out unless comics tan or
Latino and the first week I'm latina ex
Chapel girl she came out with some [ __ ]
about her they were pretty racist - well
actually had a bunch of racist tweets
against black people if you have one way
to sell in your body
the rest of them bro like woman talks
like this kind of thing yeah surprise
the most - when you know I'm Mexican
Kevin Hart lost the [ __ ] Oscars bro
because he could have got it back then
he just said well he lost the [ __ ]
Oscars cuz he said oh because it's uh
the gay stuff yeah the the anti uh you
know he said he'd break a dollhouse on
his son's head if you found him playing
with a doll house you know just [ __ ] I
mean come on like okay let me tell you
somebody tell me you come out to your
dad as gay and he's gonna hug you back
in the day never
after that joke that they put out well
these are tweets this week yeah what do
you think he's doing Jumanji man you
know so let's see that goes back to what
you said before we serve we started
recording which is like you can say
whatever you want to say you're not
gonna get on SNL but you can still
continue to say what you want to say and
still have a fan base and all that stuff
sure you know you're not going to be
able to work in a corporate situation or
a situation that's backed by corporate
dollars
it's just not gonna happen you're gonna
have they have to answer to someone else
they have people to get out so you have
to make you know that listen Disney owns
[ __ ] everything CIN BC and they don't
mean sorry not GM ge owns all that owns
NBC and they're they don't want any
thing on their consumer products side
they don't want a boy I mean if you if
ya dude and there's an everything I mean
chick-fil-a is getting boycott yeah yeah
it's a you know it's why with people's
money
well because it's [ __ ] their Pro they
they were supported the supported Trump
in their pro-life they supported the the
lobbying against gay marriage that's
right but I mean is that racist though
what that fool said I mean do to me
[ __ ] hates the word chinking yeah
it's not like it was like a tweet my man
had like a five minute clip around and
he's going he went on a rather but in a
podcast Oh is there a joke is versus
just talking about whatever the [ __ ]
comes to the top of your head
most times there's a whole lot can ran
through the whole day without a podcast
podcast when somebody stops with a
science show like what were they talking
about behind closed doors wondering
which people don't do anymore cuz
podcasts are popular now they got a
[ __ ] cultivate to an audience and be
a different person a know that whatever
love was nature whatever they say is
gonna be under a microscope this guy was
just having a conversation and he said
what he would say when you're looking in
behind closed doors how much [ __ ] do you
say behind closed I know history but I
know that I know that what China to honk
Chinatown was started because they were
there because why people put them there
after World War Two in concentration
camps that guy's a [ __ ] idiot bro
there's a deserter to BSNL pocket he's
the [ __ ] idiot bro I never write
stupid [ __ ] like that bro
I know about your walk bro I'm totally
unwarranted on that woke India dog how
do you say something italic how do you
not know in college and know the history
of all Chinese people [ __ ] about anybody
that's defending Chinese people not
play devil's advocate of the very large
goodnight we're talking about Chinese
commercials where they have freaking
Chinese chicks throwing black dudes in a
washer to bring them out white oh I've
seen and it's airing right now we'll do
our share first we're not gonna fix
racism by clicking on a guy that says
[ __ ] when you got a guy in the off in
the white house if you're gonna start my
album is hold on my problem with the
whole thing is Felipe here is that we
are holding these [ __ ] morons that
are in a podcast and cast knives and
they're more accountable than the
[ __ ] Supreme Court judges and Muppet
that bring their dicks out on free on
chicks faces and now they've got a
lifetime position that's not getting
cancelled we've got a president that
said grab them by the [ __ ] and [ __ ]
Mexicans are this way we're holding over
there because I'm saying we're holding
people that [ __ ] have no power
accountable for [ __ ] that flies out
of their mouths and people that are in
power we're not [ __ ] holding
accountable SNL has sponsors and those
parts are gonna have a problem by having
that guarantee goes back to business
goes back to business that game you know
the Asian Cup business I guarantee you
go back to business I guarantee you this
damn this table if anybody in this table
right now got up a position where
everything that you've said in the past
can be put under a microscope
there's definitely [ __ ] that they will
find that you said that was [ __ ]
straight down you don't think you know
catchy coming out of the blue
I don't regret nothing oh I don't regret
anything
I'm not a racist person I think I've
never said cheek I stop saying the
n-word we're hanging around you guys on
tour guys just saying a lot
you know I mean I stop changing you know
so I change with the times
no no yeah of course now in hindsight
you change with the times right I get
that 100% your things that were
acceptable like like Eddie Murphy's
[ __ ] joke you know when he said
[ __ ] you know have you ever stood
used the word [ __ ] not on TV not a
radio that a podcast okay you use it in
your stand-up but it's told me words two
words to me yeah yeah that's all you
know and I could have been smarter by
the way you know and I get what you're
saying
times change like with Eddie Murphy that
joke he's not gonna come back out like
two months ago delirious them with the
dirty places have it's a horrible word
other than we traded places so we're
gonna keep Eddie Murphy as as an
accountant are you crazy
you no matter n-word run this company
oh and you know it what you say yeah we
have to hold the upper offices
accountable the president accountable is
that but we want to I mean we want to
hold that person accountable too and I
think most people in this country do
it's just difficult to get to men
because because of that anger now it's
being focused on people who don't have
that kind of clout that we can [ __ ] up
it's misdirected [ __ ] rage I think
people are also able to control their
purchasing power now and they're
realizing the power of doing that of
having some impact on like corporations
or whatever or you know consumer
products based on I really think the
lower cuts work I don't know I don't
think I don't know they used to many
people you're gonna come yeah now if
they don't because everybody there's
we're so fractured I love cokes but
we're so fragmented in this country
there's their supporters of everything
100 so you cannot for just as many
people they're like chick-fil-a
you know in cases nobody does look at
Alex Jones like Alex Jones lost
everything people still support his
ideas or still believe everybody oh no
they're saluting there's people that had
that that March that went on the women's
March know the with all the dudes with
the tiki torches yeah that was 100%
about racists that were there [ __ ]
you know and those people are out there
screaming pretty much that you know it's
it's white supremacy it's white pop not
just [ __ ] one race [ __ ] all you
[ __ ] right 100% white
anglo-saxon prize will right and those
are the guys that had the balls to go
out there for every one of them guys
that was out there
there's hundreds of [ __ ] but
we're a home with that same philosophy
with white people dawg and they've
always been but I'm not saying all white
people are racist but but undercover not
all of them but undercover I believe
this administration has made
[ __ ] come out with balls and
bottom on its that make them feel once
like when you see like when I was
younger I see them I see and I see
George Lopez and I seen you [ __ ]
on K Lobos Iowa dude I could do that
[ __ ] dawg
if I can see you guys maybe I wouldn't
think that way though sure maybe dice is
a [ __ ] moon away yeah again like I
said I can't stand that daddy that
somebody's being somebody with no powers
being held more accountable than people
in power that is what's disturbing thing
is this is like your comedian so it's
like I'm not ignorant or whatnot but
it's like I don't really think his
intent is to hurt [ __ ] Chinese people
no I mean I don't know that guy I don't
know the guys look at it like you know
sure host modern history what were
Koreans doing a black and Latinos in
downtown LA shooting them with [ __ ]
ar-15
that considered racist or what yeah but
different that trying to get innocent
now who all regardless of the people oh
my when I come back to dinner dinner
China get out SNL
who's owned by West and how is killing
with a company man who television we
understand we can't have a guy like that
well I have no complaints be a
distraction he'll be a distraction could
we also hire a new way
guy so you can't have this is great
publicity
exactly nothing there we know what it
might be known that this [ __ ] guy
said all that let's just air this agent
dude goes higher this [ __ ] let's just
let's do it break it there and now it's
in the news and wait weeks but let's see
what's gonna really happen bro like just
I'm gonna take i'ma borrow I'm Frankie
Frankie Castile words mmm see you didn't
gonna hire him a little big in the brown
face you brown a change you think
they're gonna bring a brown out the next
Latino the next black person hell no
they're gonna find a white person who's
lesbian who who's probably dead laughs I
promise my lady
before they're gonna hire him because
that's the way white people deal with
racism by bringing in a white guy who's
handicapped that way everyone's happy
and if they forget that they never been
in a brown guy or a black guy yeah I got
I got call my right or wrong I got I got
cause I don't know what what how they do
know it helped me fix something and
brought in a black I do know that if it
goes on the air and two [ __ ] weeks
from now and people are talking nobody
would be talking about Saturday and live
the way that they're talking about
Saturday no but you do this mom asking
you who you didn't replace look at a
diversity showcase and one of the dudes
on it was a white guy who's like missing
and I was like dude go family hit
himself with a hammer that was born
leti it like this isn't it so that I
didn't see what you're saying like that
guy who have one eye that's what that
guy that guy who never made so I said I
was gonna be replaced by a lesbian
why person with cerebral palsy it looks
like a man that will you satisfy the
whole world but I just wanted to add
this little bar the latino guy
no can i I was gonna ask you uh when you
say they're hitting up people with no
cloud look at what happened with Tracy
Morgan he was on 30 rock he said they
got Walmart come on exact that's what
happened after in the erase that [ __ ]
but check it he said what would he say
on his suite if my if my
gay I would stab them they didn't take
them on 30 rock they have the same
advertisers so it's different with
people they don't have no [ __ ] just
like when you're a famous comedian with
money walking in looking at you
those kids were talking about worked
we're 12 19 22 those those kids at once
a castle were 12 when that came out none
other 22 but I would advocate Tracy came
out apologized Tina Fey behind him
rubbing his back like all right now this
dude apologized and it was kind of cocky
[ __ ] apologize a certain way he
said [ __ ] you yeah in the end I like
what you said hey I'm one of them
[ __ ] MADtv guy myself different
apology but if you don't know the system
if you're not orderly you gotta play the
[ __ ] game if you're gonna work for a
corporation you have to you have to you
have to play together so you're a
comedian and that's fine you can go
onstage and say whatever the [ __ ] you
want people could walk out but if you
want to get on a network
yeah you can't say any of our cast you
can get fired for saying a word on stage
they have morals closets in those
contracts man so much [ __ ] like I
feel bad for the generation that's
coming up we grew up a lot of new ways
to see the difference is that now
there's more and there's not before it
used to be you're sitting around at a
bar nobody's gonna know what happened at
that [ __ ] bar and I'm not saying you
know like [ __ ] you know you're
sitting there and you're drinking and
you get loaded and you [ __ ] pass out
your friends got to carry you out
probably the people that were there
would see that now you do that
[ __ ] there's gonna be [ __ ] 20 phones
in your face watching you loaded getting
carried out of a [ __ ] bar you know
what I'm saying that's just somebody
that got too loaded too happy and now
they got a [ __ ] problem they gotta go
[ __ ] do the I'm sorry
I got a [ __ ] therapy I need that's
why I'm saying I hope that for people
not only is everything that you say
magnified everything that you do as
innocent as it could be as getting
loaded and pass don't you go to the
[ __ ] bar for to get loaded and pass
the [ __ ] out you know oh yeah you're
supposed to go to have one goddamn
drinking responsibly eat a dick brought
some why I'm trying our wagon loaded we
will have four days of Willy's famous
Cordover instead of hearing about it
we're still learning about the famous
score though now within the last year
come on what's up bro you were so good I
know we were Sacramento I know I hate
how was our show back bro I don't get it
I know whatever you smoke slugs bro
that's a bug broker like Vince varnish
it has been fun he'll night out a job oh
you were inviting industry goes down
right bro I mean sold out a lot of drunk
[ __ ] they were partying their
asses off Sacramento people love it's
different now yeah I wasn't doing
nothing bro I was performing they were
loot tours with cheetah pants wearing
I'm at the same place I was over the
night before Adam the crest a crash
theater yeah yeah I performed over Luke
tourist corridor asker Gilbert Escobar
and [ __ ] Detroit had cheetah passes a
[ __ ] yellow post or well no a regular
tree locals free locals free locals 400
bus at night dad
yeah so you were at the crest yeah let
go it was good we have but the worst
green room of all green rooms no
ventilation I will say their past
agreement better than that we're talking
too [ __ ] [ __ ] TARDIS phone sitting
in the back then you got a change of
sodas and then blend the hot air from
the [ __ ] ice machine in there that's
[ __ ] horrible six guys in two weeks
but you know what you read a buck just
say you have your normal set blah blah
blah blah you know you have your [ __ ]
you know what I said but everyone
shouldn't want to trade on and you might
say something stupid and say I regret
that you always say my bad i'ma say that
yeah but now you can't even you say my
bad cuz they'll cut up my bad part oh I
shoulda never said that maybe you
remember you were tackle a heckler in
the wrong way you know they only get
that part there's a there's a super
famous stood out there and I don't want
to last anybody but I'll just say he was
at a show at a sold-out theater within
the last few years and his zipper was
down and somebody said you're super he
goes why you looking he said why are you
looking down there [ __ ] you know and
now now so now again now is that is that
it's like you know I remember when
people even people who does a Tudors 28
and Hooters [ __ ] used to say [ __ ]
like last one last one it down it is a
[ __ ] you know something like that
they were homophobic you know that's
just there was some stuff yeah that's
what I'm saying
jo koy did he mean is he homophobic I
don't think so no way it's does he hate
gays no [ __ ] way is that something
that because in the back of his head
it's something that he said before like
a knee-jerk reaction you know what at
the end so again that's why it's so hard
for me to get on board with we're a
different place yeah we're in a
different place but there's got to be a
[ __ ] learning curve bro not there's
there's for a long time look and I would
know the way to keep us in I respect
women I respect the [ __ ] out of women
but here's the thing when
when you say no means no bill burgess
did this joke when he was talking about
but what about no stop you know what and
gentlemen god damn it listen to me so he
did he did the joke there's a book
called [ __ ] the rules this book was
written about 25-30 years ago that a
woman wrote that this if you want to
date a man and you want it to work for
90 days you don't have any sex with him
and he's gonna keep asking and you just
keep dating him that's [ __ ] that's
the most horrible [ __ ] [ __ ] how did
you hire you then translate that into no
means no the dudes back in the day used
to [ __ ] or you if he wants this he's
got to work for it having to work for it
my book is this the rules it's called
the rules yeah it was called the rules
I've had it made of dudes out of making
it was a best-seller and the [ __ ]
advice that they gave on this book was
garbage bro make a guy work for it is
[ __ ] that's rape and then regrets
rapey if you say no and then [ __ ] I
keep coming back a man I really want to
[ __ ] you you're [ __ ] hot dude no I'm
working for it I'm [ __ ] working for
it you know hours were like [ __ ]
begging for fun no you don't remember
office begging for [ __ ] [ __ ] after
some lobster I'm telling you man how
everybody wants to act like [ __ ] oh I
never was a [ __ ] grass I never said
anything like blah blah Blee that yeah
he's just dude it's alive and all he's
doing is supposed to put us in our
position to be in fear and I [ __ ] go
over the boundaries out of every [ __ ]
luck well no you shouldn't cross
boundaries that you should him but nice
but you can't tell me if that's not just
as ridiculous as that [ __ ] story you
stole on toad on stage last week about
when you became new born Christian
because you were done with all that
crazy [ __ ] and that pastor was telling
you to pray away the horniness right
away the horn
this is ridiculous is that [ __ ] yeah
it's [ __ ] stupid your that's where
the lords yes that's what the Bible says
[ __ ] you shouldn't commit the sin of
[ __ ] lust and too far from that
[ __ ] book yeah absolutely weird we've
been told Bible we've been told morals
we've been told everybody should be
[ __ ] talking to people with reality
you know like [ __ ] yeah uh when a
woman says no you shouldn't have to
think in your head oh well it's because
she's a good girl and I have to keep
working dude if you're having fun 100%
I think the first no should be the old
the only no you have to hear that means
she's not [ __ ] interested you know
that that's how it should be you know it
shouldn't be well I'm gonna buy it I'm
gonna rub her feet like you just say
[ __ ] yourself she just told you know
what you're asking
I'm saying no to the way you were asking
you said Oh different approach shut up
Robin be nice I've seen my feet tell
that to women and walk away with them
dog wait a minute you're talking about
just going up to a woman that you don't
know or are you talking about you're in
a relationship relation we're talking
about 90 days you can be in a
relationship and make somebody wait your
tongue you sound like you're talking
about a stranger or a guy who kind of
knows you coming up to 90 days in a row
yeah and then they're like oh yeah and
the dudes gonna keep on asking right
that's setting a horrible no because I
don't see it as he keeps on asking you
keep going on dates there's a courtship
not that I'm saying I mean I had sex
with him the first night not with him so
I'm not saying that I've believed in
that I'm just saying there are books
even dated and it's like okay this was
I'm saying if she's talking about a
relationship there are a lot of people
who make people who make the other
person wait or they want to wait
together or whatever she want it usually
it's the girl wanting to wait and it's
more of like we'll go on dates and we
can make out but we don't have said
and we're gonna go our separate ways at
the end of the night and that's that if
you're not down for that then you're not
going to work out for her you know but
it's not like you're at you're asking
her every single day we're gonna [ __ ]
you know for 90 days it's going out on
dates together you got I mean it's one
of those you can't hold hands or make
out of two and at that point is like
this person I do not want to [ __ ] them
you know there's a lot of times it's a
woman just wanting like this is this
relationship feels like it's going
somewhere it's more important to me and
I don't want to [ __ ] it up I have this
book said that if you want the
relationship to work you must absolutely
wait the 90 days right I'm not saying
that's good advice I'm just saying there
are a lot of people who wait for this
but as a woman you know all worth it you
know you know that the guy you do but
you also know I really like this guy but
I know right away because it's gonna
mess everything up he's gonna think that
I'm not so but that's the way girls are
brought up exactly that's the problem we
need to get rid of that mentality that
because you have sex you're a bad girl a
book I saw called good girl bad girl you
know that that wasn't all she's a bad
girl because she listens to her mom so
she's pinpointed as a bad girl
no I not when we get to be regular girls
it look I'd be a good girl a bad girl
your sexuality your sexuality doesn't
work person your sexual whether you're a
guy or a girl your sexuality doesn't
define your morality right but you know
you know religion comes into play here
too which is all we also come into play
in all these people's lives that's just
foolish so your games that look like oh
my god I'm gonna say
wait for you and drop your book tells
you the [ __ ] kill all the gay people
and if you [ __ ] kill them
that's what that's the [ __ ] problem
I'm not saying this is right I'm saying
that this an influence in women so these
are raised sure but and unfortunately
yes we are taught just girls don't do
that you don't need to sit with your
legs open a certain point you know you
got to be you to learn that earlier [ __ ]
you don't you know you're not allowed to
do certain things you're not allowed to
go out you know your mom might not even
tell you you can't hang out with that
boy for you know tell you the reasons
why you can't when you say you gotta
listen to your part of a worker your
[ __ ] mom when you just your mom my
mom said the stupidest [ __ ] to me when I
was a kid my mom was a little bro rate
she was racist misogynistic homophobic
my sister I talk about this on my act
now where my sisters were expected to me
by my goddamn servants because I'm a guy
now and I'm supposed to honor my mom and
listen to her if I listen to her I'd get
[ __ ] be protested every [ __ ] chance
anybody sounds like you get free laundry
and now I got the I got the I got the
the the great end of the deal but it was
wrong now that in retrospect I'm like
this was horrible what they were sayin
hopefully each generation learns that
this is not the way to do not know
you're hoping but everybody's households
are different you don't have people
doing you've got people being raised
told that homosexuality will get you not
only is it wrong but you will spend
eternity in hell you will spend eternity
in a fiery [ __ ] pit if you're a
bastion of teeth-gnashing of Matthew 24
my son comes back that I just read the
logo of chick-fil-a was wrong
all right this week it'll be an
Arlington Drafthouse September 22 or
21st our Paso Texas
Plaza theater September 27 some of the
proceeds of that show will go to their
Paso Community Foundation Corpus Christi
Texas American Bank Center September
25th Los Angeles Microsoft theatres
October 28th September 28th Corpus
Christi Texas yes that's the day after
the 27th I'll be in a passel yeah
Los Angeles California Microsoft
theatres October 4th I'm coming to Yuma
area Winter Haven California October 5th
st. Paul Minnesota all the way standard
October 11th let me go to winter
everyone time and the time came from a
dear friend which I go across across the
board but go across the state to buy
beer and este nah we observed Arizona
times first Winterhaven
by you ma but the border yeah I get beer
yeah that's the woman is to one o'clock
in there late in California yeah we got
there yeah and then man it's [ __ ] to
care - yeah they [ __ ] [ __ ]
we're like when you do shows where you
leave the shore line you bet your hotel
room there nothing nothing everything
shuts the [ __ ] down Barbara Barbara
worth bro there's nothing no value no
same area that spa resort huh what's up
or did Lancaster bro a Barry Neal that
was a [ __ ] killer show dog shut out
too
whoever won the contest bro 10 G's oh
wow
what what you doin Lancaster I did a
show to start off the Lancaster Comedy
Festival oh nice
no the contest only with $10,000
somebody won oh well that wasn't your
show that was the guy who won is
together with less on Star Search or Got
Talent he has like impersonators you got
shows coming up for what I do next week
September 26 through 28 I'll be at
Dallas hyenas Uranus hyenas yeah and
then in the fall November I've got a
half hour special dropping on HBO super
white what's up good for the second one
out I did the show that came out in
April and now I just a standalone
half-hour yeah megohm I said that [ __ ]
on follow him because he mention Willie
Barcena what stop rolling those jokes
October 8th in Riverside California and
we are gonna start a weekly show on
Boyle Heights on the first shows gonna
be October 16 you and that guy no no
it's gonna be the roughest pulling to
put it on that show we're gonna do it
want to do try to do it once a week
yeah but it's not that show that shows
like a Friday night I believe but this
isn't try to shoot for a weekly show
starting October 16th we go a pool I got
the ice house starting on the 6th every
Sunday night we'll be doing comedy and
it's brunch right no no the brunch is on
hiatus until uh football season's over
yeah this is the so we're doing comedy
in Spanish that's cool I've been doing
Spanish comedy bro
how do we do bro he hasn't done it okay
we're doing with you he hasn't shown us
having legal difficulty holding Harlow's
with him dude The Dude's funny he is
he's one of the funniest [ __ ] I
was a joke man or the show was good
party after everybody wanted us to
everybody matter
number four we're gonna cut out to the
show yeah everybody uh we hung out there
you know they got that that there's a
big-ass bar there there's a big patio
area so I hang out there [ __ ] smoke a
little weed said hello to the peeps and
[ __ ] means good we yeah we uh you know
it's funny bro like I went up there and
then Willie went up after me right and
he goes a [ __ ] Marteen man he goes
[ __ ] he worked with fluffy forever eh
so he's been holding a lot of that [ __ ]
back you know you used to walk the relay
hey now he's like [ __ ] about in the ass
over [ __ ] over correcting a for
[ __ ] being clean I feel like that's a
relief you're better now
like you could be my team or there know
you're like glory of the community
because you you're gaining a lot of new
fans that they were never charged they
don't try bro [ __ ] ready for
slaughter before slaughter what I'm
saying as a Bangor though we we we we
went to Joshua Tree we recorded about
ten tracks October better play with
Airbnb in the house of studio ah there
is a we are babied and there was a house
but it was in a studio boy we would
drive to Mexico no couple weeks back the
place will you have in Joshua Tree that
was at their Airbnb yes there was an
Airbnb but that the studio was a
standalone studio it was an a and Airbnb
everybody was a huge huh yes seven rooms
and it's a it's badass it's [ __ ]
phenomenal on the emotional [ __ ] I did
not there I did it I did it but I've
been [ __ ] with mushrooms I put micro
dosing mushrooms no right not on me I
got to my home
what's your dosage every day you do it
every day every what every days or so
like maybe once a week you know but but
you know you said something a while back
bro it's a it's a very [ __ ] it's a
great [ __ ] statement that you made
well
on your podcast you said I listen every
once in a while I'm not gonna say I
listen to all of them but I do listen
every once in all and you said [ __ ]
go out there I think it was either your
podcast or your life well you said
something yeah
you said go out there and [ __ ] do you
if you want to [ __ ] put on a cape and
be a [ __ ] superhero be a [ __ ]
superhero like what the [ __ ] who gives a
[ __ ] what people are saying gives a [ __ ]
up people are thinking [ __ ] go do it
and I and that's badass yeah you know
[ __ ] I'll shake your hand yeah Bravo
Joe Joe Joe Diaz bro roast you know what
if you're a [ __ ] plumber start a
Twitter bro if I say if I need a plumber
and I know that the [ __ ] [ __ ]
plumber follows me I wanted to have a
band I'm like well why don't I do a bad
why don't I [ __ ] say I'm gonna be the
[ __ ] I want to be a rock star what the
[ __ ] am I waiting for go through a dog
go do it put an album out there's gonna
be somebody that [ __ ] likes that
[ __ ] you know [ __ ] man bro
there you go so but but my point is that
that's that's fantastic because that's
ice I never vocalized that yeah but I
started thinking that like I wonder I'm
in that [ __ ] van you did oh yeah I
did but I'm saying like wanting to do
something and doing there are two
different animals so when you said put
on a [ __ ] cape and be go [ __ ]
captain blah blah blah [ __ ] you know
what [ __ ] yeah what okay please done
yeah like Elvis hey but I remember what
time you were talking about the you see
[ __ ] I Missy on stage right now and
[ __ ] somebody was talking about
you're at a taping he's all [ __ ]
somebody talking about I wanna do
stand-up will get off your lazy ass and
go here to [ __ ] today that was me
that's that
yeah yeah this is the second coming and
he looked at me and it goes well then
[ __ ] go get a mic
all right so how many of you in a band
now original people buy all original
people or just me home well yeah there's
a guy my parents and in Paris in the
guitar lead guitar that I wanted to hike
we went to high school party at the same
time he was in a band called disabled
children of America at the time that's
like the mr. show and sketch about the
band indomitable spirit remember like
they all had handicaps and David Cross
has no arms yeah homie so uh but yeah
dude that there's gonna be an album
coming out that were happier what's the
band name Walt Lauder here's the thing a
slaughter otter starter before slaughter
but here's the thing we [ __ ] buy a
goddamn tour bus before we got a tour so
we're doing high school at Orion it came
the bus came from a greek orthodox
church called st. nick Tereus and and so
it was a race but you could still see
st. nick Tereus Greek Orthodox Church
Irish of course bro I get [ __ ] stone
and I'm going to [ __ ] with Saint Nick
Terriers and I start looking up Saint
Nick Terrace and this dude he's a
[ __ ] turn of the century Saint early
nineteen hundred's is when he died this
[ __ ] guy wanted to be in a band where
uh when he died when he like he suffered
his whole God you know Saint suffer they
got some you got a [ __ ] they gotta
treat you like [ __ ] before you get
sainthood right you can't just have a
good life and be a [ __ ] Saint
yeah and so this [ __ ] this [ __ ] had
a hard [ __ ] life he dies in a
hospital he's sharing a room bro what a
dude that's a pet that's paralyzed from
head to toe and the minute that he dies
that's when his first miracle will
happen they started taking off his
clothes to prepare him for to take him
to transport him and they put his
clothes on the [ __ ] dead dudes bed
which is [ __ ] like as a dead I mean
they put the dead dudes clothes on the
dude that's parallel
and me if I'm a patient and you're
putting a dead [ __ ] thing I
mean I'm paralyzed but I'm still here
[ __ ]
why you putting these [ __ ] clothes
over here you standing but apparently he
stood up and started walking homie and
then the room had this aroma like lemons
right it was winter it was winter so
they buried him right by the monastery
right because they didn't want to take
him out it was too cold to go out there
so hey I'm bare so he started appearing
to everybody and they're like he started
appearing and peachy numb and then like
[ __ ] when they're it's time to move
the body like [ __ ] six months later
they opened it body's still preserved
and they had lemon flowers and the lemon
flowers were still blooming bro yeah
[ __ ] six months later and then the
[ __ ] lemon flowers went away they
died after they got exposed to the
elements you know they went they took
them they moved them and then that stay
still it made him a saint and then he
[ __ ] when they moved him to the
[ __ ] cemetery so then once they're in
the st. they said oh we got to move on
with the rest of these other [ __ ]
Saints let's bring his remains they go
still [ __ ] preserved smelling like
lemons and his head and ten years later
dude still smells like lemons 20 years
later they opened it up
does he still there smiling like he
disappeared he was gone and so everybody
was devastated where'd he go he was
doing miracles for me and he appeared to
this lady hey hey hey don't trip I'm
gonna go appear to the rest of the world
but I'll be back tell him to unbarring
me like in five years there'll be some
bones but I got to go spread some Saint
Nick Terriers love finally bro the last
miracle when they finally brought him up
again and he's there a bus had broken
down on the side of the road and the
smell of lemons was so strong that it's
at the place and it went to the broken
down bus right and there was a woman in
the bus who was a woman of [ __ ] ill
repute one of them ladies I'd like to
[ __ ] right and so she said what's that
smell and then it goes [ __ ] it smells
like [ __ ] and they go what st. Nick
Tereus doing [ __ ] miracles up there
so she went up there she prayed and she
[ __ ] no more right have a nice smell
lemon so my band I'm like you know what
how do we not call ourselves st. Nick
Terriers bro
we got to be st. Nick Terriers and if
you fought your pussy's gonna smell like
lemons bro we're gonna sell [ __ ]
lemon scented [ __ ] underwear
everything bro but yeah so it's st. Nick
so the band is now st. Nick Tereus after
I found all that [ __ ] out I can't keep
calling it slaughter bro slaughter was
in the past Brown slaughters and they
threw a little jackets Arnie
yeah so [ __ ] now that story sounds
insane I wanted to be but but those
dudes [ __ ] everybody he's one of the
most like if you see his picture you're
like what's his name Victoria yeah
that's a serious
yeah Nick Dario's nectarine and and and
in spann in our Greek it's nektarios is
how they were pronounce it but in
English would be nicked arias but yeah
of Aegina yep
he knows [ __ ] lemons we're so fool
your shows coming up like I said I've
got those shows and then nothing until
[ __ ] nothing booked anyway I'm to
[ __ ] New Year's on me well how about
the the battle is that gonna play we're
gonna play we didn't have another
[ __ ] crazy show we're gonna wait till
the album comes and no Halloween show
this year why not at harvelle's
a [ __ ] another boo Ganza they're
waiting people the people wanna bro any
cons or whatever the [ __ ] I'm Nick
Terriers answer oh you got a funny
person here but oh [ __ ] yeah
congratulations dude it's a [ __ ]
bad-ass
thank you yeah however after you had a
party at her bells no no we had three
space we had the band there too long ago
we had a [ __ ] show with the band like
back in early April when you were giving
out condoms condoms before like you were
like a priest and you give another
commutable
I was going and edibles and wine yeah
look bad out yeah I had
I was almost like an altar Dana's
communion there a dating game and and
what a crazy a stripper who was buzzed
and like what would you like in the
first date you thought she was gonna say
something like flowers and [ __ ] you put
in my ass best material right away a
minute yeah téa's got shy after that
whip it up and then we went up there and
sang like Christmas carols and [ __ ] you
started singing and making up your own
goddamn lyrics yeah my silver lace one
of those I don't know but you don't
maybe we should [ __ ] plan one a
breeze a band bro listen to songs yeah
tell you're playing guitar or ligature
blindness doing Tanya's doing a rhythm
guitar [ __ ] dude I didn't realize she
was that [ __ ] talented she used to
play for in a male a male in an
all-female band that was sponsored by a
Marilyn Manson so she's like I mean [ __ ]
she's its chick does it all bro she's
[ __ ] comedy she's doing cooking she's
doing [ __ ]
perdu scenes she produced a music video
for her friend where we're Tanya shot
and [ __ ]
it's called Mexican fruit stand man
we're like it's like the dude selling
fruit out of his little chingadera but
in the back of the pad although this
mallet is going on there's [ __ ] like
drug mules there's [ __ ] murders there
so yeah but so in the fruit stand is
just a [ __ ] affront you know which
[ __ ] it's a good little short story
with music you know but that's time to
strike are you guys wearing songs
original song 100% original songs we
don't do any cover songs they're all
100% you know we've got a song called
666 which sounds cliche but we went to
the Rob Zombie Show
and Manson and there was still a bunch
of upside-down crosses and 66 yeah and
I'm like is this really still scaring
people like this [ __ ] in 83 it was great
what disrespect yeah those artists
there's no great artists or great live
dog they're keeping up but I'm saying to
myself all still getting shocked by this
I'm saying
and so I so I said you know [ __ ] 666
is evil but people are chopping off
heads you know 666 is evil but [ __ ]
kids are getting shot dead 6 is evil but
priests are [ __ ] kids 6 6 6 people
around up in my food there's [ __ ]
waters full of lead song lyrics 6 6 6 is
e up in my food crosses at the end it's
just like wake up wake up you know that
doctor we're doing that kind of [ __ ] I
got a song called [ __ ] thoughts and
prayers you know it goes
give me thoughts and prayers I'm hungry
and I'm cold give me thoughts and
prayers I'm unemployed and old give me
thoughts and prayers
I hear they fix it off thoughts and
prayers better than gold thoughts and
prayers we've been sold and then it goes
if they're good enough for that and then
it goes if they're good for dead kids
they're good and then we do that a
couple times and then it goes real
[ __ ] punk style and I'm real I got
the brayer shove them up your ass [ __ ]
your thoughts and prayers show them up
your ass
[ __ ] your socks a prayer shove them up
your ass doctor prayers don't fix [ __ ]
that's a prayer
don't fix [ __ ] bodies in 20 minutes my
brains in high school but yeah that's
that those are the kind of songs that
that we wrote you know I mean it's not
[ __ ] it's not all anything that's
gonna change anything but it's [ __ ] oh
I'm thinking to myself if I'm gonna go
out there and scream I might as well
[ __ ] scream something that means
something to me
hell yeah you know so so that's that
we're supposed to those
so the band they're gonna play live
anytime soon hopefully when we do the
record release which should be late this
year early next year hell yeah we will
find you well you're not in Mourinho
comm all the links to everything is on
my website so Martine Moreno Doc Martin
Moreno Punto palm lingual wizard
Monsieur
Eric Rivera Comedy Rik Rivera comedy on
Instagram you guys know Rodrigo Torres
juniors on all platforms you how the
Spanish going good
same bro you know what I I feel really
I'm not trying to toot my own a GG roads
right away did you
yeah how'd it go good rose hot up there
but it was good I'm doing some shows
this weekend out in Palmdale and in
Apple Valley I'm going out to those to
[ __ ] around but it's a whole different
animal also I don't feel it is but you
know what at like when I was 4 when I
first went up I started like translating
every word for word and then I realized
okay this isn't gonna so then I said I
gotta get the theme out yeah and so as
long as I get the theme whatever words
it is to use that you know what I mean
so well yeah what the ice house every
Sunday starting October 6 stop by I'll
be at my desk booking your Spanish shows
what's up fool Thank You Man